in early february of this year a group
of lawmakers in south dakota tried to
pass a bill to ban radical medical
experimentation on young children under
heavy pressure from business groups like
the Chamber of Commerce the Republican
dominated legislature voted it down why
would they do that well as you probably
guessed by now it's because conducting
radical medical experiments on children
is now popular these experiments are
justified in the name of transgenderism
the failed South Dakota bill would have
barred doctors from performing sex
reassignment surgery on children under
the age of 16 now these are radical
often irreversible procedures that can
include double mastectomy x'
sterilization and castration the bill
would have also barred doctors from
prescribing hormones to aid in the
transition process once again only for
those under 16 now it used to be that
everyone agreed with this idea it was
common sense adults are free to do
essentially what they want but if you're
15 or 9 or 10 you are too young to
consent to profound acts too young to
consent to sex too young to have your
sex organs cut off it's simple
this has been an operating understanding
in the West for a thousand years but the
reticence to mutilate children which was
once now morally obvious is now seen as
bigoted as the transgender movement has
grown activists have pushed to
transition children at younger and
younger ages for children with gender
dysphoria at a sufficiently young age it
has now become common to place children
on drugs like Lupron which suppress
hormone production thereby block the
onset of puberty at least one Democratic
presidential candidate has endorsed
providing these drugs puberty blockers
at taxpayer expense so the question is
our puberty blockers safe and the answer
it is we have no idea if they're safe
Lupron was initially developed to treat
advanced prostate cancer in elderly men
a case in which severe or long-term side
effects were not much of a concern the
drug has also been used to treat
precocious puberty that's a rare and
harmful condition where children as
young as 5 undergo premature hormonal
changes but what's the effect of
blocking puberty possibly for years on
children who don't have any underlying
medical cause to do so we don't know the
answer to that activists
the drugs effect are fully reversible
but we don't know that that's true
besides delaying physical maturity loop
run also affects a bone density
there are thousands literally thousands
of young adults who took lupron as
children and now I have to battle with
bone and joint problems more common in
the elderly a few small studies also
indicate that when used to arrest
puberty Lupron can lower a child's IQ
cognitive ability by seven to nine
points which is a lot if that's really
the case it wouldn't be surprising since
puberty is crucial to completing the
brains development and speaking in the
brain the rush to place children on
puberty blockers is justified on the
grounds of psychological health gendered
is for kids who can't go on hormones
right away we are told will likely
become depressed or suicidal okay but it
turns out that depression is in fact a
known side effect of puberty blockers
irony of irony in a recent study from
the UK after a year on puberty blockers
children were dramatically more likely
to agree with the statement quote I
deliberately try to hurt or kill myself
while they were taking the drugs so far
there are zero long-term studies looking
at the physical or mental effect of
healthy children going on puberty
blockers whether they later go through a
full sex change or not similarly we know
almost nothing about the long-term
prognosis for children who undergo full
physical transitions it's simply too new
we don't know we do have studies though
on what happens to gender dysphoria
children who don't receive puberty
blockers in about eighty percent of
those cases boys who wish they were
girls or girls who wish they were boys
eventually get over it and turn out fine
with no radical treatments necessary as
adults many of these children become gay
or bisexual but they still identify with
their biological sex and they do not
want sex change surgery think about that
that means that most if not all children
with gender dysphoria should wait until
adulthood to transition otherwise the
vast majority then will get expensive
invasive potentially dangerous possibly
irreversible treatments they never need
it and in the end wouldn't have wanted
anyway but activists can't wait for
adulthood they want any children with
gender dysphoria to be pushed into a
full transition as quickly as possible
in other words they want
actors to carry out a vast human
experiment with this nation's children
your children as its subjects and it
really is a vast experiment in 2009 the
UK's gender identity development service
or gids
receives 77 referrals for child gender
dysphoria a decade later they received
almost 2600 that's an increase of more
than 3,000 percent notably while a
decade ago most gender dysphoria
children were biologically male today a
majority are biologically female so why
is that seems worth finding out and
despite the professional risks some have
tried to do so in 2018 Brown University
researcher Lisa Lippmann found that many
teenage girls are abruptly identifying
as transgender after seeing a friend do
so or after being exposed to pro trans
material online and there's an awful lot
of that in other words impressionable
teen girls may literally be taking part
in a fad a fad that involves
irreversible surgery at the end of it
here's a terrifying quote from The Times
of London a mainstream British newspaper
and we're quoting here 35 kids
clinicians have resigned in the past
three years many alarmed by the rush to
medicalization and the way Instagram
trans influencers and the CBBC program
I am Leo present transition as
uncomplicated they say they are seeing
girls with the panoply of other issues
anxiety depression self-harm undiagnosed
autism victims of homophobic bullying
and sexual abuse for whom transition to
a male body was presented online as the
universal panacea often a normal
tomboyish disgust at their new breasts
eliciting sudden and unwanted sexual
attention from men he's interpreted as a
certainty that they are in the wrong
body yet if instead instead of
interrogating these underlying issues
clinicians are told to affirm a young
person's trans identity and prescribed
puberty blockers that trans campaigners
fiercely insist are their right unquote
think about that's horrifying that's not
medicine it's something else
at this moment 19 US states banned
so-called conversion therapy for minors
that's a therapy that claims it's
possible for gay people to become
heterosexual the states have banned it
even though it involves no surgery no
medication no physic
treatments on the grounds that it
doesn't work and it could drive gay
teenagers into depression or suicide in
effect and this is the key those states
have said that if you want to provide a
risky elective therapy with no proof
it'll work you have to wait until a
child has become an adult that makes
sense similarly many states banned
minors from getting tattoos for the same
reason that they're permanent and they
can change your life forever so kids
ought to wait till adulthood before they
make that choice this used to be obvious
once again but on the far more radical
treatments used for transgenderism
states are doing nothing at all
South Dakota lawmakers had the chance to
say no and spared their children from
this insanity but they declined to do
that why well the chamber of commerce
attacked the bill they said it
threatened the state's economic
development and apparently Republicans
in South Dakota agreed shamefully and by
the way it really was Republicans who
did this the South Dakota House has 59
Republicans and just eleven Democrats
the Senate is 30 Republicans to five
Democrats and yet a bill to protect
children from medical experimentation
still couldn't get through the
Statehouse remember the Republicans will
do almost anything to protect businesses
access to cheap labor but your children
protecting your children they won't lift
a finger
[Music]